now for more on the problems with cyber
crime we're joined by joachim bula from
the i.t association bitcom good to have
you with us and let me start with a
personal question
listening to all that cyber crime do you
still do online banking is it safe oh
yes i do yeah of course i secure my my
personal computer but i use online
banking it's very comfortable and very
easy and makes you you know saves a lot
of time not walking to the bank with his
old formulas definitely definitely and
if you feel safe then that's fine with
me now bitcom your organization
represents more than 2 000
companies in the digital sector among
them also many global players how are
they affected by cyber crime well
cybercrime is
is a big problem in the internet
the more digitalization in the economy
you have on the other hand you have more
crime you have like good things and you
have bad things like in real life and of
course we have some more cyber crimes in
germany here for companies as well as
for customers but some more is
actually not quite to the point because
cyber crime is on the rise fast the
number of registered cyber attacks has
actually risen from about 3 million in
2009 here we see it to a staggering 43
million cases this year so it looks like
those hackers are gaining the upper hand
oh yes every third small million sized
company here in germany was affected by
a cyber crime so the problem is getting
bigger and bigger and you have to
prepare your company for these attacks
you have to prepare your your com your
company for these attacks and you have
to you know invest more in
get the cyber crime get the hacker and
you and and you have to do more
insecurity from the state but how do you
explain the global players like sony for
example becomes is a vic
a victim of hackers i mean are they too
naive why don't they invest enough why
do they not have the expertise
you know security was long time just a
cost factor for the management and
and who is investing in a thing that you
know it's not bringing more money itself
but it's so important and if you see
these examples then maybe we hope and we
see that companies rethink their
strategy for safety and security and
that's very very needful